are you following what's going on with
Disney you're following like the whole
yeah going back yeah I'm gonna read this
to you guys because there's a new story
that came out uh on the direction these
guys want to take it so Disney
shareholders tell CEO
stop wasting money on political uh
Crusades okay a Disney shareholders
speaking out against the company's
involvement in Florida politically
politics by actively opposing the
republican-led parental right in
education bill championed by Republican
Governor DeSantis Ray Keating and
Economist and editor at Disney Business
Journal said when companies dive into
politics it rarely turns out uh uh well
here's a suggestion for Disney stock Bob
shampik uh get back to business that is
excellence and storytelling and stop
wasting shareholders money on political
Crusades that have nothing to do with
Disney's business we all have the right
to have our voices heard on issues but
not on the shareholders dime Keating
said interesting yeah very pretty
powerful statement what do you think
about what the Keating said you know
you're used to uh strength coming from
Disney for what so long you know uh what
40 something years yeah they had two
CEOs right including one of the greatest
I just Bob Iger who just retired I think
chepeck is coming across as very weak in
this whole situation when you want to
come across as strong he's only been in
there for a little bit over a year you
know it always befuddles me because why
a company would want to be so
politically active I just don't get it I
keep saying to myself there are other
people who have different political
beliefs that like to go to Disneyland
and like to go to Disney World and what
happens when they do start boycotting or
not downloading the app anymore right
because it's all about streaming for
Disney and and jpeg comes from the parks
business and I think that's where you
could see the biggest drop uh when you
come back and you realize the prices
that are involved in going to Disneyland
or Disney World for the day and then to
think that okay am I really if I think
differently than how they project their
beliefs am I going to be welcome there
am I going to have a good time so is it
worth it to invest a full day in it I
just think the numbers are going to come
back I think this this board member
nailed it I think he's speaking for a
lot of people and it and it's not just
Disney I think there's a lot of
companies that are going to be having
these same conversations because once
this start once the my I know or the the
probably the quiet majority starts
speaking a little bit more they're going
to get attention of these CEOs and the
board of directors because how long can
you take it you just cannot continue to
take it like this so yeah shopping when
he came out I I was I didn't do enough
for you I just thought that was weak
talk from a CEO didn't you I mean the
memo that he sent out to his employees
it seemed like the only thing he cared
about was his employees feelings and I
maybe I'm old school but when you work
for a company I think there should be
part of you that is appreciative for the
job you do your best and you don't have
to let everybody know all day long how
you stand politically so I judged him by
what he uh released in that statement
and I think he's going to have a
challenge I really do I also think
Disney's in a very tough position
because if there's one company that is
kind of in the middle of all the drama
that's happening in the United States
right now it's Disney think about it I
mean how many of their employees are
lgbtq they just had a major walkout
right you're you're you're there
supposed to be entertaining families you
have ESPN right right all that that's
you know that's in addition to you have
amusement parks so you're dealing with
masks no Mass Pat did a whole segment
about the difference between Disneyland
and LA versus Disney World here in
Florida and Orlando right you're dealing
with kids so you're dealing with
especially with LGBT that don't say gay
bill over that critical race Theory
being taught in school
um just it's sort of like a Bellwether
of what's going on in society and now
you have the daily wire what is that Ben
Shapiro's organization that's coming out
and they basically said they're gonna
pump in I don't know how much millions
of dollars to creating more conservative
type content so Disney's in a very tough
place like what other whatever Direction
they're gonna go They're Gonna piss
somebody off and if there's a company
that doesn't want to piss people off
it's the company that stands for family
values and and entertainment and it
there's just a slippery slope into Tom
Zander's point just get back to business
have you ever read any biography on Walt
Disney which I've read a few of them
what a man what a great guy you know I
mean I mean he had his faults obviously
but when he started that company it was
pretty simple like he is you know it was
a simple
um thing you know we wanted it he wanted
to entertain families and the most
magical place on Earth yeah and it was
pretty simple I mean now they're been
pretty complicated yeah it's a giant
obviously this is the trajectory of
maybe of what companies and corporations
do obviously you always wanted growth
you always want more money you know and
that kind of maybe that's the reason why
these companies Twitter and everything
else you see and like capitalism some
drop-off is going to happen and then
there'll be another version of it or
something like that but there's always
this trajectory of like and I see Disney
going that way too it's like this is
what what would what would Walt say I
always say what would he say you know he
was a Savvy dude though there's a story
that came out I saw a couple weeks ago
or maybe over the weekend but watch this
one what's going on in Orlando so when
they beat be when they built Disney
World Walt Disney lobbied the government
in Florida to basically circumvent the
county Orange County and be able to
build as much as they want when they
want to build a glass tower that's 25
stories tall they don't need County
approved oval right so I think they pay
for their own management of the streets
Waste Management all this thing so it's
almost like their own ecosystem but
Republicans in Florida are starting to
look at that and say you have one hell
of a tax break here you have an
incredible advantage that we're going to
examine right now that has flown under
the radar screen for about 50 years and
there are going to be ways politically
for a little payback here that's ironic
that the Republicans of Florida want to
regulate Disney I don't know well let me
let me let me say this part to you so so
this is what makes me think uh oh and
I'm gonna push back with you guys and
see what angle you take with this I'm
actually curious to know how you process
this we we talked about Nike when Nike
decided to side with Kaepernick after
the whole thing with kneeling I was oh
my God Nike stocks gonna drop Nike
stocks gonna drop they're gonna it's
just horrible I will never buy another
Nike boom they made four billion dollars
like the next two to four weeks whatever
it was they embraced and they're saying
they're like ah no this is what we're
doing you know so so no we don't care if
you're going to be offended or not we
think we're doing the right thing
Disney's doing this year and I was like
oh my gosh I will never watch another
cartoon again with Disney and all this
other stuff okay
we're about to find out if this
boycotting stuff is real or if this
boycotting stuff is fake the one part
that I think is different the one part
because I hear this argument from both
sides that I think Disney's doing the
right thing from uh the left is the the
one thing that uh I will say is how
different this is than others is a
following is we saw what happened in uh
Georgia it was a Georgia Virginia we saw
what happened
where the the main topic that parents
United on both sides of the aisle
politically where one side's like listen
I'm pro-choice okay well I'm pro-life
okay uh I I'm I'm about to you know
entitlement programs I'm not I'm about
minimizing it okay I'm about we're
spending too much money military well we
need more military to be unsafe okay but
don't mess with my kids
yeah me too don't mess with my kids oh
so we have that in common yeah what are
let's unite and then boom election
Showdown what happened so the the
difference I think how Disney's going to
be going up against Nike is this is kids
and if they think for a second that's
going to be okay with parents I I think
I'll point out one other thing too right
you know I think Nike was defending at
one of their Stars which is different
than defending you know an employee that
works at a desk or at a cubicle which is
what Disney's doing the other thing is
Disney's political beliefs come through
in their product right so it's not like
Nike was only making left shoes right I
mean you still love Nike right but with
Disney it's coming through in their
movies and in their product and it's
coming through on ESPN the other thing
is there's a hell of a lot more
competition for Disney than there is for
Nike and Disney's trying to become the
number one streamer in the world and
they have a fight with Netflix and maybe
with Amazon and so I think there's less
margin for error for Disney air I think
it can hurt them more down the road
because they have more competition and
it's constantly throwing in people's
face is how they feel politically right
when you sit there and you talk to your
average day person they're going to show
you pictures of their kids what do
people care about what do they really
care about I mean mean the average
person here's my kid doing this here's
my kid doing why they care about their
kids you want to see the average Joe get
fired up and want to kill something mess
with their kid right so that's where I
think you're right where it's going to
be like it's a little different a little
different when you're talking about
someone's because you want to see a
general populace get angry but what's
the thing that we covered last uh last
podcast or last week uh with Jank I
believe that they they're going to stop
referring to kids as boys and girls and
now dreamers and wishers or something
like that yeah so when you know you know
what percentage of society doesn't want
to be identified as hey good morning
boys and girls ladies and gentlemen no
nobody has an issue with that but now
you're canceling the word boys and girls
that's where you get people with common
sense being like hold on I was with you
guys yeah but yeah what's going on here
loud I'm out you know Kevin said earlier
that uh the nation is lacking religion
and it's it's not you're just seeing
instead of God they're filling it with
politics and this is becoming a form of
religion Hollywood
the politics the intersectional stuff
the Mac the the vaccines the climate
change it's all becoming a form of
religion if you don't follow the
Orthodoxy whether or not it makes sense
whether or not it's truthful whether or
not it's backed by science if you don't
follow the Orthodoxy you are a heathen
of sorts and you get cut out and cast
out You're Gonna Worship something you
know I don't know because the human
beings we worship things you know and so
you're going to worship something it's
not if it's not God it's going to be
politics it's going to be uh woke
politics it's going to be uh the moon
and the stars
your own reason it's gonna be you're
going to worship something and so we're
finding that it's shifting now we're
getting away from God we're going to
other things all kinds of different
things
and they're not good if you enjoyed this
short clip click over here to watch
another short clip and if you want to
watch the entire episode the entire
podcast click here
[Music]